abetto o'rourke confronted the texas
republican governor and lieutenant
governor yesterday at a press conference
about the uvalde texas shooting and beto
was marched out by police officers okay
uh there are some who are saying this
was a despicable
uh a grandstanding attempt i completely
disagree a beto is actually showing
passion and concern for what's going on
beto is not blaming doors like
republicans and clies increasingly are
let's look at the confrontation you will
hear that as uh governor of texas greg
abbott who said mental illness is the
only problem here greg abbott tries to
turn it over to dan patrick
of the lieutenant governor and then beto
interrupts and then they start insulting
beto and telling him he's uh
embarrassing or whatever and then beto
is ultimately removed by police this
time i will
pass the mic to lieutenant governor dan
patrick
excuse me
excuse me
excuse me
sit down you're out you're out of line
and an embarrassment
so if you're listening beto has now been
approached by police
right now and you're doing nothing no he
needs to get his ass out of here this
isn't the place to talk to him this is
totally predictable
sure you're
[Music]
they do not like being confronted do
they and you see ted cruz like a statue
on the stage
i'm sure you are online please leave
this auditorium
i can't believe you're a sick son of a
[ __ ] that would come to a deal like
this to make a political issue
he's called a sick son of a [ __ ] for
making this a political issue when is
the right time to to talk about the
politics of what's going on because it's
a political issue
for a republican governor and a
republican lieutenant governor
who are willing to consider any solution
to the gun violence problem as long as
it doesn't involve dealing with the guns
that's politics and this idea of oh
you're injecting politics give me a
break
[Applause]
and there is beto
marched out of there by police oh beto
was rude let's denounce him for his tone
he didn't wait his turn to speak he
didn't wait enough days before it's okay
to talk about politics beto is saying
what anyone with common sense has been
thinking and saying for a really long
time
and they are doing politics by packing
the stage with republicans they're doing
politics by excluding dealing with gun
safety as a solution they'll blame doors
rap music i'm gonna play a clip later of
them blaming rap music and yet uh shame
on beto and uh beto after getting kicked
out he kept going outside this is
another viral video more than two
million views 50th in the nation in
mental health care access 50th there are
only 50 states in the nation we are dead
last the number one provider of mental
health care services under greg abbott
in the state of texas is the county jail
system in the state of texas the largest
inpatient mental health care facility in
the state of texas is the harris county
jail all right so you get the picture
and listen beto beto did nothing wrong
when when nobody else is willing to do
anything that connects to the actual
issue
at least he's out there trying to get
some attention
let me know your thoughts find me on
twitter at deepakman we'll take a quick
break and be right back
i'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep i sleep on
a helix mattress at home i absolutely
love it and that's why i reached out to
them about sponsoring the david pakman
show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness i generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both gq and wired magazine it
is well deserved i can tell you
firsthand every helix mattress comes
with a 10 year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights and they will even come pick
it up at your house if you don't love it
but i know you will for a limited time
helix is offering up to three hundred
and fifty dollars off all mattress
orders plus two free pillows at helix
sleep.com pacman it's the biggest
discount they've ever offered the link
is down below